New York is next Sylvia is on the line
hi Sylvia how are you hi Dave hi
better than I deserve what's up you
think I have another stupid tax question
oh well we've been on your plan for
almost two years we've paid off $40,000
and we still have a lot of debt and our
lease is ending this December it was a
full year lease and my husband I
disagree on what to do with it he thinks
that we should keep it and finance it
because we're going to get a lot of fees
when the inspection comes and you know
she's also a DJ so he makes extra money
on the side by DJ so he needs that truck
to carry all his equipment so I think
that we should just return it and buy
stopped that snowball for four months
and save as much as we can and buy you
know a second-hand car so just I just
wanted to know like also going to truck
so what is this what is the buyout on at
the end of the lease on the truck oh
it's thirteen thousand two hundred and
twenty five okay and what's the truck
going to be worth do you have any idea
no I do not know I mean it's a 2013 job
let's pretend that the buyout price is
thirteen thousand two hundred dollars
and the trucks worth ten thousand you
would never buy the truck that would be
stupid
well right but let's pretend the trucks
worth fifteen thousand and the BIOS
thirteen thousand well it might be buy
it might be smart to buy it in her and
sell it for a profit that's what he was
saying so we need to compare the value
of the truck to the thirteen thousand
dollars I see and are you over on your
miles no we're under but it has a lot of
scratches in a few dents yeah you're
young you're going to get hit for all of
that that's going to be a couple
thousand bucks so all right that's all
he says else he sells cars for a living
so when we won he leased a car we it was
at up according to him like we didn't
have to give a down payment and it was a
pretty she said it was a good deal
but idea okay and now you're finding out
how stupid it was when you try to get
out of it you're going to get hit one
way or the other
so um you know so I think you're going
to have to write some checks here either
way and you just need to decide what
that is
and that just be logical about it okay I
need a truck to carry my stuff around
it's not a reason to buy this truck if
this truck is not a good deal and so you
look at what the fees are if you turn it
in and how much that cost you or you
look at if you keep it how much it costs
you and but it sounds like you probably
need to turn it in and do what you're
saying and buy used truck with cash you
know that's it but I don't know what the
trucks worth and you don't either so
that's what you got to figure out it and
you can look at that and go you know
right today it's worth X and so by
December it's going to be worth around
around X and you know andthat's begins
to tell you what it is but don't pay
$13,000 for a truck that's worth nine I
mean that that would just be ludicrous I
just adds you know it just adds to the
pile of stupid is what it does hey you
guys Rachel Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
than
save room to channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget one of the best videos out there
you